all right we're now live for the
December ask me anything session it's a
uh sunny but super cold day here in
Milwaukee I guess there's some serious
winds out there
um got myself a nice non-alcoholic
let's see who this is by Brooklyn
uh special effects hoppy Amber so some
little enjoyment for the time as we go
along we've already got some good
questions lined up and um
let's take the first one I don't have
quite the same kind of answer that I
think Carl bodd might be looking for
would have proven to be the most helpful
text thinkers in developing your ability
to sandlerize fools so if you don't know
the context of that sadlerizing was
something that got coined as a term back
when I was in grad school and
um I was pretty aggressive with other
students and even professors and you
know
um
what was it to saddlerize to like you
know ruthlessly destroy another person
show that they had no clue what they
were talking about and I don't really do
that so much these days uh I'm I'm
pretty restrained in comparison to how I
used to be and I don't think that there
was any particular philosopher who was
helpful in helping to me to do that I
was just good at arguing and I had a lot
of stuff at my disposal
and I ran into a lot of people who were
you know kind of pretentious or precious
or didn't know what they were talking
about or jumped on you know some sort of
bandwagon like you know back then
levinos was a big thing and everybody
said the same basic things about it
facing the face of the other and you
know you kind of just you learn the
shtick and you you go after them so you
know I guess the only thing I could say
is knowing the texts better than the
other people did
um what was
made it possible for me to do that I
mean I guess you could say that some
philosophers might be viewed as enablers
because sadlerizing is not good behavior
it's not collegial it's kind of being a
jerk to jerks and maybe Nietzsche played
a significant role in that I suppose
maybe sart who I read a lot of at the
time who holds people responsible for
the positions that they take so that's
that's really about all I have to say on
on that one
Galen asks um Leo Strauss considered
Heidegger maybe the most important
philosopher of his own time but said he
wouldn't meet him because he couldn't
bring himself to shake his hand because
of his personal life obviously you know
Heidegger belonged to the Nazi party is
there anyone that you feel similarly
about whose work you respect and feel is
important but who as a person is so
objectionable that while you would read
and commend their work you would not
associate
I I don't know nobody comes to mind off
hand
um
I mean
I I there's a lot of people who you hear
that they're kind of jerks I mean
there's there's probably people that
I've worked with on occasion and they
were just too much of a pain in the ass
to continue working with them again but
I don't know that any of them had the
stature of a Heidegger
so it's kind of hard for me to
think of somebody
myself who
I would um I mean yeah I mean there's
there's people that are like pop culture
gurus
that I don't think I would want to have
anything to do with like Jordan Peterson
or Sam Harris or people like that but I
don't consider them to be real thinkers
um they're definitely not up to the
scale of a Martin Heidegger
um
I guess you know maybe they're they're
up to the scale of an iron Rand or uh
Oswald Spangler you know but
so there's nobody like Heidegger level
who I would say yeah I I respect their
work but they're such an [ __ ] I won't
have anything to do with them so yeah
lapse uh nine Continuum many thinkers
have supposed the existence of
universals is contrary to time in some
way
seems necessary there's types of events
for example days thoughts on the
relation in other words perhaps time and
Abstract entities are correlative or
each necessary for the other I mean I
think that totally depends on what
you're understanding by time and
Universal it's not as if there's a
single Theory out there that all
philosophers agree upon
um even when it comes to the nature of
time let alone universals so there's no
answer to that
um because there isn't any generic
universals
um
Sam says do you think there can be a
convincingly systematic view of Plato's
thought or is his works too diverse and
complex to be easily
systematized I think there are
convincingly systematic views of Plato's
thought out there I mean that's part of
what neoplatonism as a movement
consisted and it's whether you buy into
it or not they certainly were interested
in trying to bring together that stuff
and you also have middle plateness like
alchinois you know with the handbook of
platonism
I would say Plutarch is kind of doing
his own interesting eclectic thing but
he certainly is indebted to Plato
um I think if all you've got to work
with her Plato's works
um and you're trying to put together a
systematic
overarching account you're going to run
into some problems here and there so you
always got to kind of smooth some things
out right but
um I mean I would say the challenge is
actually to read and understand all
those Works in in the first place
um
vegan sports bar thought on the world as
will and representation is this an aura
text so this is uh referencing the video
that I released yesterday about texts
with uh auras meaning that they're the
kind of texts that lots of people talk
about but don't actually read much of
and
um
you know they they make appeals to them
they treat them almost as if they're
like Commodities or consumer products
somebody I forget exactly who it was
made the great suggestion that you know
we could call these texts fetishize
texts as well and
yeah I mean world is Will and
representation has had that kind of
appeal
um schopenhauer has gone in and out of
um uh favor you know when I was a
graduate student there were very few
people
interested in schopenhauer unless they
were like doing stuff on schopenhauer
and Indian philosophy and in the last
you know
20 30 years there's been kind of a boom
of interest in him
um maybe because of his pessimism you
know so yeah I think there's there's
quite a few people who
like to talk about schopenhauer but
haven't actually like worked their way
through world as well and representation
um
it's like you know I mean there's a lot
of texts out there that could be or uh
tax text with auras that people are
chattering about but not really
um
reading
um
Rob wickline why does nature have such a
big problem with dialectics I don't know
that he has a big problem with
dialectics it's not his uh not his style
I think he thinks that um the way in
which
um hegallian
dialectical thinkers because that's
mainly what he has in mind I mean he he
complains about his own early work as
being to to along those lines it's too
neat you know it's um
the the idea that you can bring things
together into these
comprehensive views that take in just
about everything and you know uh sublate
the important stuff in there I need you
just doesn't buy that
um but I I don't think that you know
complaining about dialectics is really
something all that Central in his his
work
um
Jake says do you have any thoughts on
the writings of Isaiah Berlin or general
opinion of him as a philosopher it was a
great word Smith
um he was you know interesting and in
terms of like uh formulating stuff that
we can uh play around with like you know
distinction between negative and
positive Freedom
um I don't read an awful lot of him
um so I'm I'm not at this point in time
although I do need to like actually do a
few videos on some stuff for my my
students I haven't like read around in
his work all that much so I don't have
much to say about him
um Rob can we recognize differences
among objects without connecting them to
a Genus yeah why not
um I I don't know that we have to uh
have a you know
big like hierarchical structure in order
to recognize differences between things
uh Jay crass philosophical question
mustache or go team not a philosophical
question at all
um and uh you know I don't I don't
I don't know what we would um
uh say about that I mean I've got both
right by by virtue by virtue of having I
go to you have a mustache I suppose you
could say
all right uh who do we have next
um
maximum do you think it's necessary to
read Khan's critique of pure reason
before reading hegel's phenomenology of
spirit two of the texts that have a big
Aura you could say no
um and why would you think it's more
important to read Khan's first critique
than read his second critique or third
critique I mean the phenomenology of
spirit is less about epistemology and
metaphysics and more about the
development of human culture and there's
you know massive sections devoted to
Ethics in there so why would you think
that one critique is the most important
one unless you've like just heard that
it's an important work
um I mean if you want to like set up
prerequisites for understanding Hegel
Aristotle is just as important as Kant
is you know
um and uh
you know you probably would also need to
read some of the people after Kant that
are that are closer to them and you
definitely need to read a lot of
Rousseau as well so I I this is kind of
a
um a non-starter question I mean the
first time you read the the
phenomenology you're only going to get
maybe you know at Best one-tenth of
what's going on in it anyway you're
gonna have to reread it so you go back
to it right
Nest mask what are the current
assumptions about the concept of quality
I don't know I don't have any idea I
don't know what you mean by that Dean
what is platonic dialectic broadly
construed and what is it not so
dialectic is is one of those terms that
gets used by different people in
different ways
platonic dialectic you know is talking
back and forth about something some
people sometimes people want to say Well
it has to be question and answer and if
you actually read Plato's text sometimes
it is and sometimes it isn't
but it's something that you work out Dia
through uh you know legging talking or
speaking with with each other
and you know you try to zero in on
definitions if they're possible to
provide there's a lot of like let's make
some assumptions clear let's examine
um accounts and arguments and that
that's what platonic dialectic is I mean
sometimes it's talked about as composing
and dividing and sure that's part of it
as well
um I don't think there's anything
particularly
mysterious about it it's doing what we
do in in philosophy and in so many other
fields of life
you know I mean I think you could say
that one thing that is key to it is that
there is a connection between in in
Plato's text between the style and
approach of a person and their character
and their structure of motivations
um and that Socrates also is very very
interested in seeing what people think
not just what they think other people
think but what they they actually think
for themselves you know
um Rob says I'm rather confused about
the difference between end and good in
the nick of McCann ethics I've read the
glossary entries they seem to share so
much overlap I can't totally Square
where they start in the end well there's
your answer
um there isn't a lot of overlap so don't
try to separate them out from each other
an end is something that you're aiming
at ends are Goods Case Closed you know
um I think a lot of cases like this you
want to avoid like confusing yourself by
importing assumptions about how things
have to be same or different
uh Ben cloak what do you think of
Heidegger's dasman do you think it's an
accurate depiction of social life how
much do you think it plays a role in
Heidegger's Nazi views I don't think it
plays anything in Heidegger's Nazi views
it's it's an independent concept that
you can find in plenty of people who are
not Nazis or people before they're Nazis
like Heidegger didn't join the Nazi
party at the time that he formulated
that concept
um
dasman just means like the crowd or you
know the the they is how it's usually
translated and I mean this is a common
place in existentialist Philosophy from
Kierkegaard all the way on through you
know nature and shastoff and people like
that you know Gabriel Marcel uh talks in
similar ways John Paul sartz talks in
similar ways the idea is that there's a
well or take it you guys that's another
great example
um there's this sort of like flattened
out
um everyday superficial people uh living
lives that uh lack what you know rilka
would call Solitude and
um you know people who kind of you know
they have an identity but it's it's not
really their own identity it's just
something they've kind of accepted and
they engage in superficial customary
ways of of engaging with each other in
the world and you know I think is there
a truth to this this idea sure yeah I
mean again Heidegger's not saying
anything that's particularly new here
um
it's just got a different name than than
what Kierkegaard or Nietzsche or chest
off or you know Ortega gossip called it
um
so yeah and I don't think it has any
intrinsic connection to Nazism
uh Saeed I've been reading trying to
read up on German idealism for someone
who's quite a novice in philosophy of
what philosophers do you suggest I begin
with and where do I go from there let me
Kant
and uh you know I would say uh if you
want to like start out with the easier
Works read the prologomina which is
supposed to be a you know summary of the
first critique it isn't really but it's
it's good enough uh the groundwork for
the metaphysics morals and you know you
might actually want to read the actual
metaphysics of morals um you can get a
good idea about what kant's project is
by looking at religion within the limits
of uh reason alone
and uh you know you want to read there's
a whole bunch of different people that
figure into German idealism and are also
critics of it but you know who are the
most important people you know ficta
shelling Hegel
um I mean that's going to keep you busy
for a long time just poking around in
their works so and once you do you'll
get a better idea of who might who else
might be interesting to take a look at
uh ridicules his thoughts on these sewer
socialism movement in Milwaukee is that
something like the framework you'd like
to see socialists take in the present I
don't even know what sewer socialism is
um it must be pretty obscure if it
hasn't got onto my radar as a matter of
fact I should probably look it up and
and since it's in my hometown uh
uh I probably haven't done a great job
of um
getting getting uh
their word out oh okay so looks like
um
there's a bunch of different entries for
it
um reformism rather than Revolution
focusing on sort of miliarism cleaning
up the legacy of that oh great yeah so
that's I think that that sounds like
good stuff overall
um it's not something I was familiar
with
all right
um
vegan sports bar have you ever read any
Vladimir nabikov yeah I read Lolita back
when I was in college because it was in
our world literature class
and uh it wasn't for me it wasn't quite
interesting enough for me to want to
read anymore nabakov
um I you know with a lot of these
authors it's unfortunate that you read
them because they've got this massive
reputation and you know they're like oh
you must read these people
because I I was kind of disappointed
with the work I didn't find it as to
live up to the hype and so you know
given the scarcity of time I just never
got around to reading any other uh
nabikov
um
so useless projects has an interesting
one you once answered when you when
asked if you could meet three people
dead or alive who you'd like to meet
Socrates wouldn't be a choice because he
thought he was a bit of an ass why do
you think he's an ass read the platonic
dialogues and then see what you think I
mean he uh makes you know he in the
apology he says oh you know people's
charge that I make the the bad arguments
seem good or the weaker arguments seem
stronger he does that sometimes right he
makes bad arguments and in his stuff and
he pokes fun at people and
um you know he goes to dinner parties
and wants to interrupt it with all sorts
of philosophical conversation and
sometimes that's cool and sometimes
that's being an ass you know
um I don't think it's it's a very
controversial view unless you like
lionize Socrates to say he is kind of an
ass
um and I don't think I'd want to hang
out with him you know
um
so in Z who's your favorite philosopher
as I always say I don't have one will
you do anything on Asian philosophy I'm
not a specialist in Asian philosophy
Xeno I've been following your lectures
on anger it's been insightful
yeah there's there's uh there's a lot of
great philosophical works that people
don't often read having to do with anger
it was viewed as a central problem in
ancient and uh I think you could also
say medieval and even really modern
philosophy how to understand and deal
with this emotion but most of the
discussions of it get kind of uh
overlooked unless you're in a psychology
or a philosophy of emotion class or a
psychology class if they actually read
any texts and uh you know so it we
probably should raise some of those up
uh Andy a metaphysic philosophical
question do you think we should believe
philosophical claims on testimony
Keith Allen claims we shouldn't since
philosophy is not truth directed never
heard of Keith Allen uh and why somebody
would say philosophy is not truth
directed that's kind of a non-starter
for me uh philosophy is truth directed
maybe the way Keith Allen does it it's
not
um and I don't know what it means to
accept philosophical or believe
philosophical claims on testimony I
suspect he's using that in some you know
jargony specialized way
uh rizar does Nietzsche hold the noble
and slave distinction could it be the
case that this distinction as a
temporary view one that set ups a
possibility of going Beyond Good and
Evil
um no uh this isn't this is absolutely
integral to niche's work I mean it shows
up in so many different works it's not
just something that's temporary
and what you've got mixed up there is uh
Master morality is
Beyond Good and Evil it's because it's
good and bad not good and evil slave
morality is uh is uh good and evil
that's how it it structures itself
so no that's that's uh I mean there are
some things that were I think myself
like Eternal recurrence of the same a
lot of people make a big deal out of
that I think that's not that that
important for understanding Nietzsche
um but Master morality and slave
morality as valuations that's absolutely
Central to his work so
um
Frederick what does epistemology mean in
Philosophy for you well it's a domain of
philosophy it's uh you know concerned
with some really Central questions like
what's what's truth how do we know
things and you know we engage in it all
the time like when we're thinking about
should I accept this claim or not what's
my basis for that it's not just
epistemology but that's that's a good
part of it
um so you know like like most terms in
philosophy it's got multiple meanings
um I can't read that that person's what
I'm assuming is perhaps uh Arabic
writing are you interested in
post-modern philosophy I'm interested
mostly in in people getting the term
post-modern right
and uh you know
it was it was developed within French
philosophy uh leotard you know puts it
out there and it it means a number of
different things
um it doesn't just mean the same thing
as relativism or you know it's not the
same thing as late 20th century writing
or stuff like that so it totally depends
on what you actually mean by postmodern
but I think you can take a look at my
YouTube channel and figure out whether
the authors that I've covered count as
post-modern and uh that would answer it
[Music]
um
Xeno do you think if God doesn't exist
it would be necessary to invent him no
um
I mean you could have uh a conceptual
scheme that doesn't have god with a
capital G
um there's all sorts of available
thoughts about what exceeds you know
Humanity or what transcends us or stuff
like that
um and you know why would it be
necessary and then you'd have to say
necessary in what what sense like
logically necessary
probably not
um necessary in order for people to feel
that there's something more out there I
mean even in ages of Faith half the
people don't believe because you just
look at their behavior and you can tell
that they they don't you know
uh silent mandible do you think Martin
boobers I and thou can be related to
dialectics
uh depends on what you mean by related I
mean boobers uh position is is developed
dialectically and it's you know the eye
and thou are engaged dialogically
so why not
um but which dialectics do you mean you
know platonic dialectics as we talked
about earlier Marxist dialectics
hegelian dialectics other people's you
know later conception of dialectics
Aristotle's understanding the stoics you
know I mean dialectics is not a term
that you you can use without qualifying
what kind you mean
um diogenes the cynic favorite worker
but ties I imagine you're not as keen on
the fiction compared to a cursed share
eroticism it's been a long time since
I've read but Thai
um you know he was kind of you know sort
of a underground big thing when I was in
grad school so I don't really have a
favorite work of of his I would say
all right
um
available Baggins do you think
philosophers should believe their
conclusions
is philosophy today utterly distinct
from the philosophy of Socrates the
stoics there is no such thing as
philosophy today
uh any more than there was any such
thing as philosophy in ancient Greece
there's philosophies and they overlap
and they intersect and it's very
difficult to make accurate
generalizations that aren't going to
have all sorts of exceptions about any
era of philosophy
um I mean you can answer your own
question by thinking about whether there
are people in the present doing
philosophy who engage with Socrates or
the stoics and the answer of course
would be yes
I'm one of them you know and there are
many others so is is it you know utterly
distinct
of course not I mean are any
philosophies utterly distinct from each
other what would it mean to be utterly
distinct you know
um laps for Continuum here's an
interesting metaphysical question what
is the soul on your view
I mean I would say
that I am
uh not quite a substance duelist right I
think that the body and whatever we want
to call it the soul what exceeds the
body are very closely interconnected
um but that there is something more than
just this right
um and I you know
I don't have a hell of a lot more of my
own views on that I mean I I have a lot
of other people's views handy about that
sort of thing but I can't quite say that
I have you know some sort of well-worked
out position of my own I will say this
is a little bit of a joke you know and
some of Canterbury was one of the
smartest guys of his time and on his
deathbed he uh he lamented the fact
according to his biographer that he had
not um started on the next big topic
that he had wanted to talk about namely
the nature of the Soul because he didn't
think that anybody else in his time was
actually going to make any progress on
the topic so
all right uh Oliver Marcel says have you
read Robert Bolano and or Julia Julio
cortazar uh nope I haven't read either
of them nor have I even heard of them um
but that I mean don't take that too
personally there's like tens of
thousands of people out there authoring
Works in philosophy and uh obviously
most of us have have not encountered
even more than a small sliver of them
um
Beach sweater just a shout out
philosophy major from University of Iowa
here nice to see someone giving this
kind of exposure
accessibility and intractability to the
subject for others unimaginable 10 years
ago
yeah I mean that's kind of an
interesting thing to say
um what was YouTube actually like
10 years ago and were there any
alternatives that would allow us to do
this this kind of live streaming thing
I I you know I suspect they're probably
was something but it just wasn't well
publicized you know and when did YouTube
come up with live streaming I mean it's
it's been quite a while because I think
my first things that I did were maybe
like 2013.
um so you know it's it's not quite 10
years ago but it's close to 10 years ago
but I mean that was pretty small scale
compared to
what it's like now in the present and
there's so many other platforms that you
can live stream on that people I guess
are doing philosophy on I don't know if
it's any good you know the stuff that
you're going to find on like twitch or
Discord or you know other other things
because I don't have the time to you
know check that stuff out
um but yeah it is pretty cool and I I
mean we're pretty lucky that we live in
the era that we do because
I mean if if I'd been born 20 years
earlier I you know I was in terms of
like uh traditional academic stuff I was
making some pretty significant Headway
um you know publishing a couple articles
or book chapters a year getting invited
to participate in things you know
working on book projects as well as
doing my my traditional teaching
but you know if this medium hadn't been
available I I wouldn't have like sought
it out
um my first actual uh foray into
recording a lecture was when I was
teaching at Indiana State Prison and the
place was on lockdown for like five
weeks and I went out and bought a video
camera at like Best Buy and recorded
myself in my uh basement Library office
and put it onto a VCR cassette took it
to the prison and of course it was a
complete mess they didn't play it at the
right time for my students and they had
all sorts of other people coming up to
me afterwards saying you're that guy on
the on the video you know and uh
you know that's that's that was the
state of the art back in 2005 2006 or
whenever it was so yeah things have
really changed quite a bit
uh silent mandible have you heard
anything about the newly discovered
Hegel papers yeah they they seem to be
early stuff that has to do primarily
with Aesthetics which sounds very
interesting
um
I don't I don't know if they've actually
gone through all of them at this point I
haven't I haven't been paying you know I
saw the the the uh
news when it came out and then there
were all the jokes about oh it's going
to like radically revise you know what
we're saying about Hegel and stuff like
that or you know
jokes on you if you think this is going
to make Hegel any more comprehensible
um and then it's just been kind of quiet
because I think now they have to figure
out what they're going to actually do
with them you know
so
um
it'll be interesting to see you know I
mean hegel's Aesthetics is not an area
of his work that I have any real
familiarity with so
I'm not I'm not particularly well placed
to say much about it
um per weasel uh do you have any
suggestions on what to read after
reading Kierkegaard doesn't have to be
existentialism read whoever you want I
mean
if you're if you want somebody who
references character guard then I mean
you could read existentialist authors
because they tend to be pretty big on
him or you might like say well did
Kierkegaard actually get Socrates right
uh let's go read some platonic dialogues
and some xenophon or did Kierkegaard get
Hegel right maybe we'll read some Hegel
or
Kierkegaard also you know Praises
Descartes in some places so maybe you go
and read some Descartes it it all
depends on what what your your goal is I
suppose
um
Kyle says do you prefer Hegel or
schopenhauer I know I don't prefer
either I mean they're
um
they're they're both good uh I I will
say this because people you know every
month or so there's somebody who asks me
about it is if they're like informing me
about something I didn't know about when
schopenhauer is criticizing Hegel you
know if you know both authors you just
kind of ignore that as the the ravings
of a uh mostly on point but at that at
that point Envy driven
um bullshitter you know but you know the
rest of schopenhauer's stuff is worth
checking out uh it kind of depends on
what your your interested in you know
they're both uh they're both good
authors neither one is like the author
who's got everything figured out so uh
Cornelius you said in the past that
demons is your favorite Dostoevsky novel
but you never made a video about it do
you have any plans about that in the
future yeah I mean I I think that would
be kind of kind of fun to do
um I haven't done any Dostoevsky for a
while usually I'm doing stuff for my
classes and
um the demons just isn't uh or the
possessed just isn't a book that I've
been um teaching in in my classes so
I've been you know focusing on stuff
that I have been teaching like Joseph
Butler and you know Plutarch and all
those people but I mean down the line I
would I'd actually like to do that
it does remain my favorite of his his
novels
um I think it's got the most interesting
stuff going on in it I know a lot of
people are like no crime and punishment
or brothers karamazov and those are good
but
I find Brothers karamazov kind of a a
slog
um
and you know
uh I won't I won't say like some people
oh you could have trimmed it or
something like that no it is what it is
but I just I I'm not that interested in
reading the whole friggin thing again
whereas you know
maybe I'll reread the the demons and the
possessed over Christmas break I don't
know
all right
um
Oliver Marcel curious about your take on
Canal's guard I don't have a take on
Canal's guard because I haven't read
Canal's guard
um
one 1.2 what's the relevance of ideas
such as substance Essence universals
particulars and so on modern philosophy
and Science in general I don't know I I
don't know there's an in general for
that uh there isn't a modern philosophy
in general
um so that's kind of a non-starter jake
when was the last time you were
surprised by something in philosophy oh
that's that's a good one
[Music]
um
yeah you know let's think about
different ways you could be surprised
you read something and you're like holy
[ __ ] I didn't realize this person was
interested in this and had something to
say about this or knew about this right
and then there's the being surprised by
like how good something is or or
sometimes being surprised how bad
something is
and I'm kind of a forgetful guy so I get
surprised quite often
um
and I would say you know I'm teaching
this this class on Plato's dialogues
online and we've been we went through
the ion the Youth of fro and the apology
so far and now this coming week we're
doing The Credo and then we're spending
two weeks on the Fado and I'll probably
reprise that class next year sometime in
my uh reason I owe teachable Academy
um rather than on White Hall as a side
note too by the way light Hall is moving
towards like workplace development kind
of stuff and away from philosophy and
music so I'm not going to be doing any
more classes with them after this one
um but you know re-reading the apology
which is a text that I teach you know
probably
um at least once a year
um
there was there was you know and looking
at it closely not sort of like thinking
about okay what am I going to do today
let's talk about the three main groups
right
um it was interesting to see him talking
about
the um story of you know his smart ass
friend Kyra Fran saying is Socrates why
is there anybody wiser than Socrates
right and there's there's a couple
shifts you got to be careful when you're
reading platonic dialogues and Socrates
is playing around with terms
because the Oracle did not say that
Socrates was the wisest
but Socrates at a certain point says
that the Oracle said that and you're
like whoa that's not actually what the
Oracle said and you're like what's going
on here so that that's kind of an
interesting surprise
um
millward says do you think
existentialism philosophies ruined a lot
of things now no and I don't I don't
know why anyone would um think that I
mean
existentialism somehow had the cultural
significance to ruin a whole bunch of
things
I mean what fantasy world would you have
to be living in to buy into that kind of
story or who who's you know whose take
on the history of ideas would you have
to buy into to to believe that
um Rob wickline what x-rate philosopher
do you consider Foucault I mean probably
second right
um I think that Foucault for all of his
um you know historical research you know
sometimes he says stuff and you're like
ah come on that's not what the text
actually says you know he's he's clearly
like taking things and turning them into
a narrative that that works for him and
he's you know he's a good researcher
[Music]
um
I think some of the stuff that he says
is quite interesting I don't know that
it's like world shakingly profound
um
you know that reminds me so like going
back to this text with aura thing right
if people were like super into Foucault
I think it kind of changed from time to
time like you know for a while the order
of things was the book to read and then
it was the history of sexuality because
sexuality is so sexy right and everyone
was talking about the care of the self
and stuff like that
um
so what what would it be now I don't I
don't know I think I think it's not as
if there's like a centralized Foucault
community
um
let's see here
uh canalius how is schopenhower's
peculiar thoughts about women viewed or
talked about in Academia does it get
brought up alongside his series of on
series I mean schopenhauer in general is
not getting brought up a lot in Academia
and you got kind of a broader topic here
of male philosophers saying stupid
things about women
um
you know I mean Nietzsche if you read
Beyond Good and Evil
um
there's like you know in his discussion
I'm trying to remember which chapter
it's in like the this basically the
second half of the chapter is just
blathering on in Stupid Ways about women
and you're like
do these guys actually understand women
do they are they just misogynist do they
just not pay close attention you know
similar with Aristotle saying dumb [ __ ]
about women
um I guess I just ignore that stuff now
because Life's a little bit too short
and you know uh I'd rather spend my time
on on intelligent conversation rather
than silly [ __ ]
um
so how is how does Academia look at it I
mean I think you've got some people in
Academia that will do the gotcha thing
see look how bad he is you know but
I think most people if they're reading
schopenhauer are reading schopenhauer
because
they want to focus on what's actually
worthwhile in his his books you know
so uh Xeno says I'm reading the ancient
city of collage or by collage a book
about the laws of Rome but a bunch of
other stuff wondering if anyone else
here has read it yeah I read it years
and years ago
um I mean I I think I was still in grad
school when I read it so it's been a
long long time philosophical Irish drunk
will we ever do a series of symbolic
mathematical logic there's no need for
me to do so there's already people out
there doing that uh my time is probably
better spent focusing on things that
other people don't do quite as well
logic is pretty straightforward and easy
to do well I think you know
um
1.2 thoughts on the concept of view or
views and philosophy I don't know what
the concept of that is uh if philosophy
is the Endeavor to truth can there be
only one correct view for each question
ever that's easy to answer no there can
be multiple correct uh views because uh
maybe views have to be put together you
know
um
feel king or something is that a Denim
and Leather shirt any good metal albums
you enjoyed this this last year yeah it
is indeed let me see if I can show it to
people
Saxon Denim and Leather one of their
um great albums songs ideas you know
um I wear this to the gym quite quite
frequently and uh I've been fortunate
enough to see Saxon twice hopefully I'll
get to see him again sometime before you
know they uh run out of steam the time
that I did see them
um they were doing pretty good so uh
metal albums from that I enjoyed this
past year lots and lots and lots of
stuff I mean I post about this in social
media
when I'm at the gym
I'll typically take a screenshot of my
Apple music of what I've been
um see what I've been listening to
lately and you know a lot of what I'm
doing is like re-listening
um I should probably just like look at
my my photos and see what I've got in
there so like last time I was at the gym
I was listening to Angel witch's debut
album and Samson's uh
um head-on album really great that's
with you know Bruce Dickinson as their
singer
um here's you know Saxon the power and
the glory uh Ace Freely Friendly's Comet
which starts out with rock soldiers
which is an awesome song
um
uh let's see who else we've got in here
uh just scroll back like a million years
stupid iPhone
um yeah I mean I I could go on and on
and on maybe I don't want to waste too
much time on doing this but I you know
I'll listen pretty frequently to stuff
um
and
we were doing a thing reviewing more
recent albums by classic metal bands
um we got to do some of that in the uh a
classic metal class that Steve Scott
Caroli and I were doing before we kind
of got wrapped up in in stuff
um oh you know somebody I'll recommend
so
Gillen
um if you haven't heard Ian gillen's
stuff that he did as a solo artist
really good
um he he's somebody who I think is kind
of under underrated
um
all right dog wow why do philosophers
look down on the Practical applications
of philosophy in the real world as being
not that important how an ideal reel is
important as it may have to change to
work I mean who says that they do I mean
some do some don't
um clearly I'm not one who looks down on
practical applications of philosophy in
the real world provided people are
actually applying the philosophy and not
you know some watered-down version of it
um I think there's there's you know
there's people who don't like it and
then there's people who do like it
um
but I think that there's more and more
recognition that philosophy had better
provide some sort of accounting for
itself or else people are are not going
to fund it you know
um made of clay here's a good
pedagogical question
how do you view failing students not
ones who slack off per se but once who
just weren't able to do well enough to
pass
do you have a philosophy about failing
students besides the one given by the
school I mean I grade people on the work
that they do
um and sometimes people can't do the
work for a variety of reasons I mean I I
just had one student who I'm going to
give an incomplete to
um because the poor guy got covered you
know and uh
he was doing okay until he got it and it
messed him up pretty bad and um
I've had it myself
um and I haven't you know physically
been the same since covid but then again
you know I uh I had a couple other
strikes against me I've had some other
autoimmune issues with uh mononucleosis
as a kid had had limes twice you know I
uh
uh I'm diabetic so and and covid messed
all those sorts of things up I'm I'm
lucky that you know what didn't happen
was reactivation of other viruses I've
also had chickenpox too so unfortunately
I have the shingles vaccine and you know
covid put me out for like a good week
and a half
um and then I had lots of fatigue and
you know I have more muscle and joint
pain since it than I've had before had
some brain fog
um so who knows what this poor guy is
going through right
um
and I'll give him his incomplete and
he'll either get the work done or he
won't and if he doesn't I don't hold it
against him a lot of students will email
me about you know like
being behind and they feel ashamed or
upset with themselves or embarrassed and
I actually put a page in my my classes
that says when you fall behind read this
you know and I stress to them that
academics are not you know the totality
of a person's life or value or anything
like that sometimes people have have
troubles right
um and I have I have a lot of students
who struggle so what I do my in every
one of my classes I let students hand in
late work all the way up to the end of
the semester
and I usually don't penalize them for it
if they have any kind of good excuse and
I have no problem giving students
incompletes which allows them you know
like at Milwaukee Institute of Art
design an additional 30 days to get work
done now if they don't get the work done
in that time then they get an f and
that's just the way it goes but I don't
I don't you know look at them bad
because they got an F
um
all right let's see here
just skipped a little bit
um
Johan how do you square your Catholic
faith and your work as a philosopher and
a pluralist and secular Academia I mean
that's not a challenge at all at Angel
son and and uh you know uh Maurice
Blondell did that I mean and that was
over 100 years ago so why would that be
a challenge of any sort you know
um as a matter of fact there's probably
more room in today's Academy for having
any sort of religious Faith than there
was in the French third Republic so
all right vegan sports bar on your video
of prudent priorities how does one know
what they're good at and what to
prioritize I'm in my early work 30s and
feel unrealized well you figure out what
you're good at by trying things out and
seeing what you have some enjoyment in
and some aptitude for I mean some things
you can figure out you're not good at
right away some of the things you're not
good at you might be able to improve on
but you know you have to figure out
whether you're likely to make you know
progress and then you got to decide what
you you want your life to include you
know I mean all of us can look at
um so you know here's a prime example
right I I play bass guitar
um and I'm never even gonna be Nikki Six
good to use uh one of the phrases of one
of my friend blitch
um who played in bands in in uh New York
and la and then you know moved out to LA
and started his own fashion line how he
does drug and alcohol
counseling and he's very very good at
that
you know he realized that he could be
Nikki Six good but he was never going to
be Steve Harris good but most of us
aren't going to be Steve Harris good
somebody who is potentially Steve Harris
good is
um I forget her name but she's the
bassist for the Iron Maidens and she we
saw her on stage recently uh well we saw
the whole band on stage I was watching
her primarily uh because you know I I
like looking at the basis and she was
just amazing
um playing Steve Harris's stuff
is uh pretty extraordinary
um Steph Harris is is what she goes by
Wanda Ortiz is is her actual name Steph
Harris is her uh stage name and um you
know am I ever gonna be at that level no
I'm never gonna be at that level so I'm
not gonna like prioritize bass playing
in my my life but you know you got to
try things out and you figure out what
you're good at and then you decide not
just in terms of those things but also
in terms of your other life priorities I
mean do you want to have a spouse do you
want to have children do you you know do
you want to travel
uh do you want to put aside money for
retirement all these things are also
priorities right for your life do you
want to learn how you want to learn
other skills like how to cook well uh
which can contribute to all of these
other things in in important ways so
these are all things that you got kind
of have to think through and now to go
to I'm in my early work 30s and I feel
unrealized okay I I can relate to that
um
I think we all go through things like
that except for those who are really
lucky and like find they're calling
right away and there's a need for their
calling right away right uh that's not
most of us I think most of us do have uh
and maybe other people want to chime in
about this I think most of us have
feelings of not being fulfilled at
certain points or not being you know
fully realized our potential is not
being met in in certain respects so I I
will hopefully that helps Jonathan
rosensweig says any connections to be
made between Heidegger's essay on
technology the question concerning
technology that is and social media like
Facebook or Instagram are they standing
reserves so standing Reserve is a key
concept that is coming out of that right
and the idea is that
um
let's call them just matters in general
become
viewed as something that is
uh numerable and can be drawn upon and
used like put into you know a process
and with Facebook or Instagram or
Twitter or anything like that it's not
the platform that is the standing
reserve the platform itself you know
there's this um
this slogan that if you're getting it
for free you're the product right and
that is the way that things
that's what's being done to human beings
through the social media they're they're
constantly gathering information on you
right so Facebook years and years ago
started putting together these profiles
on people as does Google as does
Microsoft all these big tech companies
are doing that and you know they figure
out an awful lot about you by what you
post and how you respond to things and
sometimes even like how long you spend
on on something
and all of this winds up being digitized
and exploited and you see that you know
like Facebook sold a lot of people's
information right to to allow them to be
exploited in terms of uh commercial
matters and and
um voting and politics and and stuff
like that so yeah I think I think that
um we could say and it's not just
Heidegger and the question concerning
technology that would be useful you
think about um going back to Kierkegaard
right and a lot of people
have drawn connections between his
discussion of the public and leveling in
the present age and and social media
there's there's quite a few things we
could talk about Nietzsche's master and
slave morality perhaps in that respect
or I actually this is you know this
would be kind of an interesting thing to
turn into a class wouldn't it looking at
Tech platforms and what they do with us
but I don't know that I would be the guy
to do that so
hey Bruce Bruce Moore is here as well
long time uh
what we would you know interlocutor
who's become a friend over the years so
good to see you there as well
um
let's see here
Sam Brinley what's the correct
philosophy that depends on what you want
to do with it I guess right Kola moose
um not a question but some news oh this
is good I recently received news I got
into St John's College I want to thank
you for all the help you and your videos
they've given me with my studies so call
the most is another uh long time
interlocutor a young person who is uh
Rising I think Rising senior
um
who's uh been involved in discussions
about speculative fiction and you know
if you don't know about St John's it's a
it's a college that is devoted this goes
back to the dialectic thing to engaging
students dialectically you you study
texts and you you know you have a um I
forget exactly what they call the people
that are essentially like tutors they
come in and they they like you know
provoke you into thinking about things
and it's very very interactive I don't
know if I could be a professor at a
place like that frankly it might not be
good for for somebody like me
um but yeah that's that's really
wonderful news so I'm happy to to read
that as you know do you like when
nietzsa wept I haven't I haven't seen
when nietzsa wept as a matter of fact I
really haven't seen I should spend some
time watching movies about philosophers
because there's that Hana rant movie and
stuff like that so I should check that
out uh Siddharth says is there money in
philosophy sometimes and sometimes not I
mean is there's money in anything I
suppose and you know there's certainly
people out there who figured out how to
make tons and tons of money out of um
peddling uh watered-down philosophy
because that that tends to be what sells
but if you're doing you know real work
maybe not quite as much but I I've
certainly been able to make a living
with it but I've been pretty fortunate
uh Mohit I am from India some tips for
language I'm not sure what what you'd
mean by by that
[Music]
um
I mean there's a lot to say about
language but I think I need some some
further prompts
um
VV no question but I'm hoping you're
doing well I am I am doing pretty well
you know uh the semester is coming to an
end
um and uh that'll be nice because I'll
have more time to get things done before
the next semester starts
um looking forward to some down time
Siddharth did you read any of the Hindu
philosophy yeah because I've actually
taught classes on you know uh not just
world religions but also non-western
philosophy but I'm not an expert and I
don't read you know Sanskrit or Paulie
or any of that sort of stuff so I'm
always a little bit
um humble when it comes to uh
willingness to to talk about that kind
of stuff Damon any advice on how to
learn to read Greek
um
well I mean the way that I learned
languages is not generally the way I
suggest to other people to learn to read
languages I I think it's good to like
take a course you know and when it came
to Greek that is in fact what I did I
took uh a course on classical Greek with
with starting out with Rick Williams for
a year
um who is the head of the classics
department at Southern Illinois
University long since retired
and we started out with 12 people by the
end of the semester we had four left of
those four that started the next
semester two of us finished and then it
was on to like doing readings
um you know you read some Lucian or some
Plato or whoever else uh you know so I
did some of that and then eventually
started doing like you know independent
studies but you know by the time that I
got to Greek I already had
you know a good facility with with Latin
French and German and I I was very much
into Indo-European linguistics
so you know I would look at
um the grammars and they would talk
about that stuff but I think most people
that's not particularly helpful for them
you know and I'm also the kind of person
who doesn't I'm not interested so much
in learning the paradigms I'm much more
interested in learning the intricate
connections of rules and historical
developments of language I don't think
that's particularly helpful for most
Learners you know
uh Scotland's shame I was wondering what
you think about Socrates saying
philosophy is preparing for death I'm
also happy to report the Masters is
going well here in Edinburgh oh I know
who this is
um so yeah actually I I gotta write you
I gotta email you that's a good reminder
because uh this is Andy
um I'm gonna have to see if we can chat
perhaps over over the Christmas break
um yeah so is philosophy preparing for
death yeah I mean that can be a function
of philosophy
um and you probably should think about
death to some degree because it is it is
pretty important you know but it maybe
that gets a little bit over done you
know maybe there's there's so much more
else to philosophy
um
Roman any recommendations on philosophy
in the application of it to Life as a
student so you know most most of the
philosophers that that you might read
you can ask well how would this actually
apply to the real world as we call it
right
um
and I think that's that's perfectly fine
to do sometimes you know
you know so think about derida for
example really fun to read and it's
complicated and there's cool ideas and
he's engaging all these other
philosophers it's very challenging to
think about well how would I apply this
in my actual engagement with other
people without just doing word games or
stuff like that right
um he's he's kind of a tough person to
apply
but there's some things that that you
could draw out of his work that might be
useful you know
um and you know other philosophers are a
lot more close to ordinary existence
particularly those who do stress
the application of philosophy to to life
think about William James and you know
his version of pragmatism
um I I'm a big fan of him actually I
like him quite a bit
um
all right Orlando Is it wise to start
reading the Republic never read any
philosopher any philosophy and just
getting into it yeah maybe I wouldn't
start out with the Republic
um if you're gonna I mean Plato's a good
person to start out with but I wouldn't
jump right into that I would start with
you know some of the other dialogues I
typically start people out with
um you know the ones that are centered
around Socrates trial and death and then
add to that the amino and the ion as
like a nice six dialogue starting place
um and then you can decide like do I
want to go into the Republic next or
maybe into the Symposium or maybe into
you know the gorgeous and protagoras or
you know where where do I want to go
from from there
um but there's nothing that says you
have to start with Plato you can you can
start anywhere you'd like to I mean I
certainly didn't start with Plato
um
and you know I turned out okay right so
all right uh siddart schopenhauer said
that studying the upanishads was the
Solace of his life your thoughts on that
yeah I'm sure it was a Solace of his
life and you know there's a lot of
interesting connections between
schopenhauer and Indian philosophy
different uh different things for
different people I would say
um I've never had a Solace of my life in
reading the upanishads but I think that
they're certainly interesting to to read
through
diogenes do you ever go through periods
of book burnout I bet that'd be a real
pain in the ass in your line of work
yeah sometimes I do
um and it's not like book burnout like
reading per se like I don't ever want to
read a book but maybe I don't want to
read the stuff that I'm supposed to read
or that I'm on the hook for reading and
I'd rather read some other stuff instead
you know like um so I I've been
lately
you know from my world's a speculative
fiction series
um I'm gonna be uh doing I'm just
shooting on on Hyperion uh cantos pretty
soon and Dan Simmons I wonder what I
don't need that in there
um and this is the second book in in
that series and I'm going to be filming
on those probably this coming week but
I've also been reading uh the The
Witcher stuff by sapkowski you know
here's sort of Destiny fun stuff easy to
read if I don't feel like reading the
the or rereading the Hume stuff that I'm
supposed to be shooting videos on which
I'm also doing uh then you know I'll
I'll read this and and I do a lot of
reading as well in the bath
um you know
I take baths pretty frequently because
it's great for my joint pain and I like
reading in the bath too
um as does by the way Alistair McIntyre
something that came up in a conversation
when we had that faculty uh seminar
together
all right
um lapse nine Continuum just a gesture
of appreciation for these amas look
forward to these months these every
month yeah I do too I I like doing these
um
so
uh let's see I'm going to start mostly
taking things from people that I haven't
had
um questions from so Oliver Marcel
curious to hear your view on Jordan
Peterson actually I think he's you know
not even Third Rate
um I think that he captured a certain
kind of vulnerable uh young man
Zeitgeist that was appealing and rode uh
the wave of popularity and started
believing a lot of his own [ __ ] and
the [ __ ] people were saying about
him and he's become essentially a victim
of his own success because he didn't
have uh
hate it you know for all of his talk
about like you know maturing and blah
blah blah blah blah blah he didn't he
didn't have what it took to withstand
um becoming an icon
um
and I think he's kind of a tragic figure
not somebody to to emulate or really
even to pay attention to at this point
um
so yeah that's I mean I've said lots of
things about him over over the the past
but I I think he's just kind of
at this point you know kind of a waste
of time uh unfortunately and it's it's
kind of sad to see what he's he's
degenerated into
Lionel uh what philosophical movements
that are prevailing at this generation
what do you think will be still dominant
even in the next Generations I mean I
think that the field is so diverse right
now I don't know that there are
movements that are anything other than
locally prevailing at this point in time
you know the philosophy goes through a
lot of fads
but they all tend to be pretty parochial
so I don't I don't know I can't make a
prediction about that
uh Tim Bernard and France philosophers
taught in high school do you think it's
good it's good if it's taught well I
mean it's also taught in in Germany and
in uh Portugal I know about Portugal
because some of my videos are part of
the resources used in the National
curriculum
um
I mean it can be good it can also be
stifling it depends on who's doing the
teaching right there isn't a a standard
answer for that
um
navilistic currently dealing with mental
problem because my dad passed away in
pain or in January I'm getting more and
more depressed and since today got
rejected from Rollins College so I'm
sorry to hear that
um somebody who's you know dad died when
I was quite young uh that's certainly
sucks
um I'm sure you're you're missing him
and uh the things that you used to do
together
um and um you know I would I would try
to see
if you can
um
connect up with other people support
groups can be quite helpful
um
and uh you know try to take it easy on
yourself it's it it's it's natural to be
down when somebody dies I mean you may
you may see this as kind of silly it's
definitely not like Dad level stuff but
Sassy the cat was my constant companion
and she died
um in my arms uh just about before I put
her down on on her her bed and her
special blanket and uh held her while
she died
um back in in April and I'm still
missing her every single day you know
and that's a cat
and a cat is kind of a person but isn't
really a person as such you know the
people that are close to us we're bound
to feel even even worse about that so
that is that is uh natural and okay and
um it's okay to feel depressed
um the question is you know can you
can you still do some of the stuff not
all the stuff but some of the stuff that
you need to do for yourself like you
know basic things taking showers making
food for yourself rather than ordering
in because you feel down
um getting in some walks I mean walks
are the easiest kind of exercise and
none of this is like a Magic Bullet
that's going to like you know raise your
mood or something like that but
every little bit does help you know when
it comes to that maybe doing some some
reading like I was saying some uh guilty
pleasure reading
um I really do like these sapowski books
um I'm glad that people insist that I
should do them because uh they're
they're they're quite a lot of fun
um but you know doing things like that
and and being gentle to yourself
um that it's not gonna like Snap you out
of it but it can it can get you through
it
Roman do you have any works you
recommend on stoicism and addiction I I
don't uh and I think that that is a
niche that could certainly be explored
um it's not one that I have looked in
too much
somebody who could talk about that
um you could reach out to him would be
Donald Robertson because you know he he
is a uh CBT psychologist
um and and therapist and he's written
quite a lot on on stoicism and
um mental health so he might be somebody
to look into
um that's nice laps for for nine
Continuum uh offering a little bit of
support here I think that's and also
afif that's that's really awesome to uh
to see uh m is there a compendium of all
Heidegger lectures and or letters uh
yeah there is it's called you know the
gazant of Erica right which is just
German for collected works
and for
for a lot of philosophers you're you'll
see if you go into like a major research
Library you'll typically see uh for
German philosophers you know because
optivarica for French philosophers you
know complete you know
um I don't know what it would be for
like Italian philosophers or people like
that but you'll see them like on on a
shelf and then it'll include letters and
other things you know
um and then the question is are they
translated and a lot of Heidegger's
stuff has been getting translated in the
last 10 or so years much of it is now
available in English which is really
quite cool
um I think that's a a good thing so
all right
um
falconing says I'll have to follow you
outside of YouTube from a metal related
content
do you like Paul Chains music as well I
don't know who that is
um
any bands that you know that lean
heavily on philosophical lyrical content
I don't I don't really uh know because
I'm I'm not listening to bands for
philosophical content I'm listening to
bands because I was a metal head before
I was ever a philosopher you know I grew
up listening to metal before I even
realized that it was a genre as a kid
um and then really got into it you know
I guess you could say from late Middle
School onward in the 80s
so
um yeah I don't I don't have suggestions
like that
um
big and sports bar I like I take
preparing for death as living well yeah
the two of them are connected
I do think that there is something more
to
preparing for death than just living
well
um certainly thinking about death does
help you put things into perspective
right
but um you also do want to think about
what is the world going to be like after
you exit it what are you leaving
behind and I guess yeah I mean that can
Orient your living well but you think
also about Legacy or you know what it is
that you're what what Mark you're
putting on the uh the world
um
let's see here
per weasel does learning a new language
influence how you think for example
Latin or Greek yeah I think
um it widens how you think
um
I mean it certainly affords you the
opportunity to read works
more attentively and closely I mean you
don't have to like necessarily read the
whole work in its original language
just being able to like like you think
about those lobe editions so I've got it
here's one right here with Epictetus so
it's got the Greek on one side in the
English translation an old-fashioned
English translation on the other so you
know I might be like reading it in the
English and be like that sounds weird
what what does the Greek say right and
then you can you can figure it out and
then you might actually be like I want
to keep reading this
um
so there there's there's certainly that
it's going to open up I mean stuff that
hasn't been translated if you're Greek
or Latin is good enough then you can you
can read the stuff that hasn't been
adequately translated
um which is kind of nice to do I mean
you can also was kind of funny
um I check out Epictetus translations
from the Greek into Latin sometimes
they're pretty wild too from like the
Renaissance you know when people when
translation was a little bit more fast
and loose than it is today
um so yeah I mean learning a foreign
language and it doesn't have to be Greek
or Latin it could just be like learning
Portuguese you know or learning Arabic I
mean that would open up whole worlds for
you in today's uh setting you know or I
mean if you want a really handy language
learn Mandarin you know I wish I wish uh
I'd kept up with that because boy would
that be a useful language to have
um
bernadin popping in just lost it for a
second where where did it go uh
uh area popping in to say hello and
thank you for all you do once I'm on a
grad school through which you're helping
me greatly I am set to become a patron
half our Hagel is indispensable thank
you oh you're very welcome half hour
Handle by the way is coming to a close
pretty soon if I can get my crap
together because I am hoping to finish
the religion section which is the second
to last section of the book uh this
month of December
once I get done with the semester
and then it's just absolute knowing
which will take me through you know
January and February and maybe into
March and then uh I'll be moving on to
another half hour something probably
Renee Descartes meditations
um so yeah
um
captain of the nerd guard why do a lot
of professional philosophers yourself
included just like Bertrand Russell uh
because sometimes he's full of crap you
know uh which is not unique to Bertrand
Russell but
um he's got his takes on things and and
uh he gets portrayed there's a lot of
people because his books are so readily
available right his history of
philosophy which is okay in some parts
and then you know wrong in other parts
um there's a lot of people who think oh
it's on a bookshelf it must be true so
I'll go buy that book I mean I would say
that Russell is a better historian and
philosophy than say will Durant you know
with his story of philosophy but not
incredibly better and you know Russell
was kind of an arrogant prick sometimes
to people
um I mean he's got some interesting
things I mean that that whole logistis
project is kind of cool to check out
it's a failure like most projects are
but there's certainly something
admirable about out trying that out
right
um what do you think of Marxism shaping
the future world that is as it is
shaping right now I don't think Marxism
is shaping the future world right now so
um Max Montague thanks for the Aristotle
Core Concepts just finished an ancient
philosophy class where we went through
the Nick and McCain ethics and your
videos helped tremendously oh that's
good to hear yeah I mean
um that is one text that I have done
videos covering the entire thing I think
it's about maybe
uh close to 100 videos or so core
concept videos
there's other texts where I've only done
portions of them like you know I've done
metaphysics book one politics book one
bits of rhetoric book two uh uh I I
there's a lot of other Aristotle I
probably need to do
um
Sid art I can't find any lectures on
whiteheadian philosophy of yours do you
teach that very few people teach
Whitehead these days and if you can't
find it in in the thing then I
probably don't teach it you know
um pretty straightforward I think
Whitehead is cool but I think that
there's hundreds of philosophers that I
could be doing stuff on
um there's nothing super special about
Whitehead Zach do you have any
experience with schizophrenia through
yourself or others yeah a little bit of
experience not myself I have met some
schizophrenics and interacted with them
I come from a family where the mental
illnesses tend to be bipolar disorder
and depression
some people actually just wind up being
manic like my mom probably was
um and you know I know I I've interacted
with quite a few people not so much in
my family but in other places that have
borderline personality disorder but I
don't I don't interact a lot with
schizophrenics so
um
let's see
[Music]
Dan beckline here's a good question how
do you hold your book in the bath to
make sure you don't drop it in the water
I mean
you just hold it
I don't think this is that that
difficult you lay in the water and you
know you got your book
and you hold it up you can even do it
with one hand if it's a sufficiently
small book
um so I I don't know this is not
something that I had to spend a lot of
time thinking about I think
um
all right uh
let's see here juice box please explain
the difference between agnostic atheism
and general atheism I don't know that
there's a difference that these are just
terms that people are throwing around
out there memory Rose have you read
dostoyevsky's the idiot what if so what
did you think about it yeah so I I did
read the idiot and it's been many many
years since I've read it so it's
probably due for a reread
I had read other Dostoyevsky stuff
before that
and I you know I enjoyed the idiot but I
didn't find it that I didn't find it
quite as interesting as you know like
the Notes From The Underground or crime
and punishment or the bits of brother
Carl mazov that I'd read or later on the
demons
um and maybe I missed something in it
but I I just didn't get into it as much
um
one tree four is it reasonable to sight
read ancient Greek text after a few
years of study
um
no
uh every ancient Greek writer that
you're gonna run across you wind up
having to learn some additional
vocabulary that winds up being important
for them
um and so you know being able to read
Aristotle and Plato and Epictetus isn't
necessarily going to prepare you for
reading say Greek tragedy and sight read
it
um you know you you'll certainly have
some facility with it after a few years
and you know with a lexicon you can kind
of work your way through things but I
mean I don't think that should be the
the goal to be able to sight read
because we have other stuff you know
uh Ricky the more I listen to the
apology I realize Socrates did not know
when to quit when he was ahead well
that's one interpretation of it or it
was that he knew he was going to lose
and he wanted to make some points in the
trial uh or you know there's like other
alternative explanations of it so
Casper will you do an episode series on
uh chorin uh maybe way way down the line
unless somebody wants to commission a
series I mean if anybody who wants to
um hire me to take time away from what
it is that I'm already doing and focus
on their particular thing and the same
thing would go for Whitehead if they
want to front the money to do that I'm
perfectly willing to do that because uh
that means taking time away from my my
other projects right
uh oh Ken's here Ken is another long
long time interactor uh also somebody
who knows a lot about Metal uh both uh
in terms of like the lore and
experientially definitely agree that
sapkowski's Witcher books are very good
reads yeah I was I was surprised
by how much I am enjoying them
um I I read
um the first one and the third one
because I was able to get them at a used
bookstore and now I've got this second
one and I forget what the fourth one is
is called
um
time of contempt I I so I'm halfway
through
sort of Destiny and then I'm going to
read time of contempt and I'm going to
do next year uh I'm gonna do a session
in the worlds of speculative fiction on
those those four books
um those those are really a lot of fun
um
Arturo any good book recommendations for
AI fiction that are not well known
you know I don't know that I would be
somebody who would know what's not well
known I mean obviously there's like you
know Gibson's uh cyberpunk stuff right
but I think those are pretty well known
starting with Neuromancer I mean there's
uh a lot of interesting stuff going on
with AIS in um
uh what's his name uh Ian Banks culture
series of course they play in a really
important role in Simmons's uh Hyperion
cantos
um
where else is AI playing a really
important role
um
good question
you know
uh I'd have to think about that more I
mean obviously
um Philip K dick right but Philip K dick
is very well known so I I don't know
about who does the poorly known thinker
or writers because I I don't read you
know I don't read all that widely
um
we need somebody who really knows the
field well in the Contemporary field
um
Dan Beck Lord I especially like the
discussions in The Witcher about Freedom
Destiny and fatalism I don't think I've
gotten to too many of them yet
um but I there's a lot of great ethical
discussions too going on uh
Tim Bernard do you think skepticism is
becoming some kind of political
scientism along with political
environmental movement
well they remain rational at their core
I don't know
um
I don't really have an answer to that
because you know skepticism uh are you
talking about the skeptic movement not
skepticism which is you know kind of
like a bunch of philosophical points of
view
um becoming some kind of political
scientism I mean I don't know what
political scientism means
um
will they remain rational at their core
nobody's truly rational at their core
we're a mix of rationality and
irrationality so uh the philosophical
Irish drunk that's quite a name opinions
on David Benatar anti-natalist
contemporary philosophy I haven't read
them
um
so I don't I don't really have much to
say about that I mean
I've you know I've
encountered like you could say the
fringes of the antenatalist movement but
I I've never really read anything in it
so I don't think I'd be competent to say
much
um
Ken says I think AI features in some of
uh krichton's books could be I haven't
read too much of his stuff
um Andres speaking of AI I've heard you
saying that what we have today can't
really be considered AI why is that the
case how far are we from True AI no idea
how far we are from True AI what I what
I have to say is that much of what we
have is only metaphorically intelligent
it's not real intelligence and it's
quite far from displaying anything that
would genuinely be intelligent and I
think that you know Descartes is
particularly the discourse on method
part five is a great Touchstone for this
he says what would allow us to
differentiate human beings from machines
and he talks about the ability of of
human beings to use language to signify
their thoughts and you could say well
but a machine can do that it can report
about its own condition yeah that's not
quite the same thing as thoughts
um that's following programming right
and then also the machine uh the one
thing it you know can do lots of things
really well but it doesn't have the sort
of fluidity of human beings
um being able to do many things not
necessarily well but being able to do
them human beings at this point in time
still have incredible advantages over
machines once you get those machines
outside of their narrow areas of
you know programmed competence
and you know neural networks are not
learning
um the stuff that we call machine
learning is that's just a metaphor
that's not it's not really learning it's
regurgitating uh you know digested
things that we fed it
um
so you know we're I think we got to be
careful in in talking about uh AI
um
I have no problem with people using the
word
um but you know it's still largely just
a metaphor
um and people believe in it as if it's
not a metaphor
uh per weasel do you like classical
music yeah I like some classical music
I'm not necessarily a fan of you know
all of it
um
and you know if I had to pick like who's
my favorite composer probably prokofiev
you know
um we're really fortunate in that just a
few blocks from here
we have the Bradley Hall which houses
the Milwaukee Symphony Orchestra we have
an extraordinary Symphony Orchestra and
conductor here in Milwaukee for a city
of our size and we um you know we put
aside the money to become season ticket
holders and you you know if you follow
me on social media every once in a while
you see me and Andy at the MSO you know
uh going to a performance I often will
photograph what the uh the play bill is
of that day so yeah I like classical
music
um
you know I like things other than metal
uh there's there's I don't have the
range that my wife Andy has but I I do
like quite a few things
all right well it is 1 30.
I uh have a event at two o'clock
um so I'm gonna have to get something to
eat
um but we'll go out if anybody has any
any last questions
uh for me to to tackle I can hang out
for maybe a couple minutes more and then
gotta heat up myself a meatball sandwich
that Andy made yesterday for for our
dinner uh we got a couple extra and then
I've got to get on with my patreon
supporters
oh philosophical Irish drunk favorite
drink
um
yeah I don't know that I have a favorite
drink I have I have things that I like
quite a bit I like beer you know
um usually you know good stuff not not
uh
um oh the Miller Lite sign is down
that's interesting I guess there was
high winds I was just going to gesture
we have the Miller Light uh thing which
is just piss water you know you know I
like good coffees I drink about two pots
of coffee a day from Stone Creek our
local roaster here
I like um hot chocolate you know not a
big Wine Drinker although I do like pork
quite a bit
um I'm not a big hard liquor Drinker
either you know
um
so yeah that's that's probably it
um vegan Sports Bar says love the
Plutarch series oh glad you know and I'm
going to do more stuff on Plutarch in
the future because he's a really
interesting guy
uh laps for Continuum thanks is always
for a good discussion no you're very
welcome so that's probably a good place
to wrap this up thanks everybody for
your questions and comments and I will
see you next time we do have a few
events coming up this this month like I
mentioned um doing uh Dan Simmons uh
this book and the book before it
Hyperion canthos
um
we may have a few other things that are
not on the calendar yet depending on how
much energy I end up having
um and uh yeah we've got you know
little bits and pieces here and there
and you'll see a lot of videos and
podcast episodes coming out this month
so all right I'll see you everybody and
talk to you next time